voici la voiture de la victime sous la
violence du choc le moteur a été éjecté
et le devant totalement broyée quant à
l'ambulance des pompiers
elle a stoppé sa route plusieurs mètres
après le lieu de l'impact
elle aussi est pulvérisé en arrêt
cardio-respiratoire le conducteur de la
voiture âgé de 72 ans a été déclaré
décédé
selon les premiers éléments le
conducteur du véhicule se serait engagé
à contresens sur l'a36 j'en déduis mais
ce n'est qu'une déduction et j'aurais
serait prudent mais comme on a 800
mètres d'un échangeur livre il se peut
très bien que il sortait de cet
échangeur lime et pour faire du 100 m
ça va très très vite à bord du camion de
pompier trois soldats de la caserne de
pont de roide ont été blessées dont la
conductrice âgée de 24 ans elle a été
grièvement blessé et son état a
nécessité son transfert par
l'hélicoptère du samu vers l'hôpital
minjoz notre ambulance donc revenez
d'intervention elle avait donc posé une
victime au centre hospitalier nord
franche comté
nous sommes en train de faire le bilan
donc deux blessés léger parmi l'équipage
conséquence de ce dramatique accident la
circulation sur l'a36 a été stoppé
pendant deux heures dans les deux sens
pour permettre au dragon 25 et à
l'hélicoptère du samu de se poser sur
l'autoroute 6 km de bouchons ont été
enregistrés